[Music]
when I hold a brick in my
hand I know exactly what it is and what
it will
do form is its
function that gives me
peace can I help you I'm the brick
layer sir this is urgent what am I
looking at Victor radic we need to bring
Vil out of
retirement what do you want and an old
friend stop by to say hello someone's
trying to Blackmail the CIA you can
bring down our entire Global
Network that's why I want you to go to
Greece to fix it with her it's a big
assignment for you first time in the
field no
supervisors I'm the supervisor of course
you
are
[Applause]
so what's our help I have to find him
and end
this you should have stayed where you
were cuz now that you're
back it's going to be hard for you to
leave again
[Music]
clearly
I warned you not going to get
involved you can't hide from me I'll
never ever stop
[Music]
coming oh let clone next time yes
dear
we're going on a Manhunt not building a
chimney never do a job without my
[Music]
tools